quel est votre sentiment au vu de ce que
vous voyez tombées au fil des dépêches
je pense qu'il faudrait licencier tout à
sa vente de responsables d'instituts de
sondage et comme d'habitude nous ont
trompés ont affirmé premièrement qu'il y
aurait une chute très importante du taux
de la participation c'est exactement le
contraire qui s'est passé
deuxièmement nous ont annoncé que le
front national aurait au minimum 30 à
31%
on est à six points de moins j'estime
qu'on se fiche de nous alors soit ces
gens sont des incompétents soit ils ont
voulu nous tromper et la gauche la
gauche elle fait un score meilleur que
ce qu'il a été prévu également par les
instituts de sondage dans la bêta -
devant je vous le rappelle 19
bon elle est très largement au dessus je
crois que véritablement c'est très
important c'est les journées qui
précèdent l'élection et je suis en tant
que parlementaire je pense qu'il faut
vraiment qu'on prenne un certain nombre
de mesures pour éviter d'être ainsi
berner par des gens qui estiment avoir
la science infuse et essaye de nous
convaincre que info pu voter et 2 que le
front national va tout emporter
or j'en ai marre est ce que le front
national justement est quand même très
souvent en tête en deux fois en deuxième
position pardon dans l'est que dans un
bon nombre de cantons ça risque de
changer la donne pour le deuxième tour
partout où dans un canton il y aurait la
droite républicaine contre le front
national
j'appelle à voter sans aucune hésitation
pour la droite républicaine
tout me sépare du front national je n'ai
rien à voir avec eux qu'est ce que vous
imaginez pour le deuxième tour la gauche
au pouvoir sauver quelques quelques-uns
des sièges au moins dans le calvados où
tout à fait je pense et je pense qu'il
va y avoir une mobilisation entre les
deux tours on va retrouver un classique
entre la réunification l'ensemble des
voix de gauche
en tout cas je l'espère je pense que on
s'est séparé au premier tour au deuxième
tour il faut quand même bien à voir où
sont les enjeux les enjeux c'est
d'éliminer tous ceux qui sont contre la
politique de progrès que nous menons
avec le premier ministre
alors vous ne voulez pas parler d'effet
front national est ce qu'il ya un effet
votre sanction par ailleurs
incontestablement on n'a pas fait un bon
score pour caen même pas raconter se
raconte des blagues on aurait pu faire
pire
voilà ça c'est parfaitement vrai on
maintient c'est également très vrai moi
dans ma commune et ben voila je suis
très content de voir qu'une jeune
candidat de coralie argot qu'à 35 ans
qui porte les couleurs du parti radical
de gauche est en tête avec les siens
pialot le maire de sannerville à
j'espère que également à vire avec marc
andreu sabater eh bien nous allons
gagner ce n'est pas l'effondrement
qu'ont annoncé pour la gauche ce n'est
pas non plus bien évidemment un succès
mais on se maintient et c'est ce qu'il
fallait faire
dernière question est ce que cela vous
donne à réfléchir aussi dans la
perspective des élections régionales
ça sera très dur les élections
régionales parce que nous partons de
tellement haut
globalement sur 22 régions n'en tient 21
bon alors évidemment ça ne peut pas
continuer comme ça mais je pense que
cette pré unification la normandie que
j'ai toujours appelé de mes voeux ce que
ça fait trente ans que je me bats pour
elle et nous avons un très bon candidat
nicolas mayer rossignol qui est le
président de la haute normandie qui est
soutenu parfaitement par laurent bouvet
je crois que nous avons véritablement là
une nouvelle génération qui va pouvoir
imprimer une politique de l'avenir donc
ce qui les résultats qui sortiront des
urnes pour les départementales ne sont
pas nécessairement à dupliquer pour les
élection régionales non de politique
différente ces deux actions différentes
puis de deux choses l'une soit on arrive
à redresser la politique en fonction de
la du déclin du chômage soit on arrive à
redresser l'emploi
si on n'y arrive pas si dans l'année
nous n'arrivons pas à redresser la
politique de l'emploi ne sont
sanctionnés si on arrive au contraire à
faire en sorte que grâce à la loi macron
grâce à tout un certain nombre de lois
et de mesures que nous prenons nous
avons à redresser est la politique de
l'emploi
je pense que là nous pouvons attendre de
bons résultats quoi qu'il en soit le
contexte national pourra toujours le pas
sur le contexte régional ou
départemental le contexte national il
est dominant mais il y a aussi les
réalités régionales
voilà je pense que ceux qui ont soutenu
ainsi la politique de réunification de
la normandie
ça contraste et voilà incontestablement
mais le contexte national bien
évidemment est dominant